we are live hello good afternoon good
morning good evening wherever the hell
you are in the world and welcome to
Sidetrack live solo I'm on my own it's
just me and you so I'm expecting you to
get into the comments for this video and
it was a little bit last minute as well
so we'll see how many people actually
jump on with us um but I was supposed to
be over on mcubed with our young Harr
but apparently he has magic blood he
went um about 5 hours ago to give blood
and he has still not come back so
apparently they want more of him I think
it's magical hair growing blood it's
blood that literally grows hair and
they're going to like transfuse it into
people like me and stormmy and Matt um
and then they will be able to grow hair
I think that's that's what it is
but as I was set up ready to go and
mcubed and then he decided we couldn't I
thought I would come on and have a chat
with you guys anyway so as we're
chatting please get into the comments
have any questions blah blah blah but I
do have something I did want to talk
about and that is Star Wars and Star
Trek are they going
small now I'll explain what I mean Star
Trek uh they're not planning to do any
cinema movies they are planning to do
the straight to Paramount Plus movies
and apparently one every other year
except we are probably going to get two
in the next two years because of the
strikes and because the delays to
section 31 it'll probably push section
31 is basically been push back but then
trying not to push back theard movie so
that'll be sandwiched a little bit but
they have no intention currently at
least I've pushing them to cinema
release and obviously that could change
because the merger is going through
um or somebody might come in and buy
them they might get um a decent
investment of cash and change their
minds but at the moment that is the plan
and they've got like a fiveyear Star
Trek
plan so they're not thinking about going
back to the
cinema which I can't help but think is a
shame because I mean it was the
cinematic movies that really reignited
the Star Trek franchise if it wasn't for
the motion picture being a success the
Voyage Home being a big success a
surprise success who knew a film about
movies about Wales even would be so so
good make any sense but if it wasn't for
those movies being successful we
wouldn't have got the Next
Generation we wouldn't have got Deep
Space 9 and we wouldn't have got all the
new track
so um soon there'll be just two more CW
shows yeah yeah um I haven't watched
Echo yet I was going to watch it tonight
but then Harris said about doing this so
he's let me down but I'm going to watch
it tomorrow instead I might start
watching it tonight after this live
actually after I get off for you guys
but anyway hey Dave hey Bob how you
doing um I tell you about talk about the
CW really quickly I'm watching um
Superman and Lois at the moment my God
that show's good tell you what I like
about the CW and it still feels like a
CW Show I don't you're wrong it still
feels like the Flash and stuff but I've
just finished the second season it's
really good um I mean it's not quite
doesn't have quite the the budget of
shows you know but Warner Brothers I
think they they I think Warner Brothers
do better with the TV stuff than they do
with the um movies a lot of the time
they um hey Sarah how you
doing oh man you're going to make me say
a world Kad deal I don't know what that
is kalal oh k
deall yeah
yeah Bob you're going to confuse me I'm
live mate so your comments actually like
will make me I will focus on them um so
thanks for that um so oh let me just a
second I'm lagging a touch and I think I
know
why that'll be
better um oh if I can come back
now so yeah um yeah I'm really enjoying
Star Wars anyway so Star Trek is staying
on the small screen now they spend a lot
of money on those episodes you know they
do spend uh over100 million per season
of strange new worlds and particularly
perard season 3 was like 120 million
dollars or
something so that's NE movie expenditure
and I would say we get more TV out of it
so I'm
happy but they're not going back to the
cinema I think there's a couple of
reasons for that
I don't think Star Trek is the um
Mammoth of sci-fi that it used to be I
think that they know a Star Trek movie
will probably not make a lot of money I
think actually though there's an element
of that as well that just Cinema doesn't
make a lot of money so um that's
probably why and it's probably not a
stupid idea to be honest it's probably
quite
sensible but then Star
Wars which is whether you call it
fantasy or science fiction I I've always
considered it science fiction myself um
even though I I do get the people that
say it's more fantasy um of announced
now that they're doing a drogu and
Mandalorian
movie the last season of the
Mandalorian had it had good bits don't
get me wrong it had good bits but on the
whole was crap it had some really
strange bits in it and it had some bits
in it that made you know that just were
laughing ably stupid to be honest like
when the dragon comes and eats that kid
and then a couple of days later spits it
out in its nest and the kids still fine
um just random bits
aoker was better but that had some
really random bits in it as well um and
to be honest the book of Boba Fett Ming
win was amazing in it she's amazing in
everything but again it add some random
bits in it it had some bits in it you
just think
sword and
sorcery um so yeah Tre gates with this
Tre and Wars going small gate going
nowhere
literally can't say about Stargate but
you're wrong um but I can't say why
sorry hopefully I show you
soon
um so yes some of the Star Wars stuff
hasn't really made sense we are getting
another season of Mandalorian and
Gru and Star Wars is in flux I think a
bit like Star Trek really they realize
Star Wars and and the same with um
Marvel that they were going the wrong
way with things they
were making stuff that people let's not
be honest let's be honest even they were
making stuff that were just people
didn't like so about a year ago they had
a big reset and they had a big thing um
you know they cancelled one Trilogy that
was planned um
we they keep pushing back the Tao white
Titi movie um I don't think that's
cancelled at the moment but it's very
much on the back
burner this um Mandalorian drogou movie
is going to be directed and leastly
partly produced by John favro which is a
good thing um I think that might be any
Star Wars fans in tell me I think that's
the what was announced as the day filon
movie is now is now this
um there's a new Ray movie I believe
coming out um of being developed which
is going to see um her trying to rebuild
the
um
um the Jedi Order um smaller can be
better just saying that to make myself
feel better you're not wrong to be fair
and we'll come back to that remind me
about that yor we'll come back to that a
sec no let's not come back to
it s
can be
better and sometimes less money can be
better sometimes a lot of the time
particularly with
franchises I think they are constantly
trying to outdo the last movie or the
last project the last thing so they're
constantly trying to go okay well we
have to go bigger better you think about
the Matrix trilogy that's uh one that
was really fell victim to this that they
had to do something because it was so
unique the original movie was so
different we hadn't seen anything before
the creators were like we've got to go
bigger and I will always argue and say
you you don't need to go bigger
um oh stop doing that sorry I'm hitting
the wrong button I've already given the
Mand Tin Man and
bogey yeah
um so by by by this constant Battle of
trying to go bigger and better and more
means that either the story lines get
complicated or a simple storyline
becomes convoluted because they are
trying to make it seem complicated and a
lot of the time the story lines get
really
confusing um think about Oceans 11 right
watch Oceans 11 very clever movie
completely made sense a reasonably
simple storyline even though you have
the big twist at the end but it was done
cleverly and relatively simply anybody
can explain to me Oceans
12 you're a better man than me because
I've watched it more than once and I I
cannot tell you what happens in that
film it made no sense or at least why a
big chunks that movie when necessary
I've suddenly realized it's a while
since I've seen it so I apologize I
can't remember the details but I
realized at the time wait if they just
hadn't have done this thing at the start
they wouldn't had to do the rest of the
movie 90% of the movie was completely
irrelevant if they just didn't do
whatever it was at the start because
they had to do all the big twisty plot
thing because they had to outdo Oceans
11 and by trying to be clever they made
themselves look
stupid that's the problem with a lot of
franchise movies Marvel is a big victim
of this because if you think about Iron
Man it's it's it's the concept is
relatively simple it's a Redemption
story for one um but it's not too big
the villains aren't too big it's it's
manageable sort of thing but because
Marvel has constantly ha to outdo itself
we then get things like the
Marvels and Miss Marvel and all these
other projects that start to get very
confusing the villains are
gods and then the heroes become
Godlike you think about the um the last
couple The Last Avengers movie if Miss
Marvel Captain Marvel are turned up
sooner that story's done you know it's
over um Avengers Assemble no Avengers
call Captain Marvel because she can just
come and uh you know thingy in the
head um it's just it's she was too
powerful the villains and the stories
got too big but also then they got
complicated Doctor Strange too
complicated if they'd have cut out about
45 minutes in that movie it would have
been a much better film the whole zombie
doctor strange thing forget it the whole
third eye thing no just cut it down
because the best bit of that movie is
when the Scarlet Witch attacks the other
Avengers that was excellent that was
really really good that should have been
the core of that movie but they had so
much ice in and so much fluff around it
it washes out all the good and that's a
big problem with Marvel always trying to
outdo themselves they need to strip back
and they need to simplify Star Wars I
think is also a victim of this they're
constantly trying to
recapture how people feel about the
original trilogy and it's not possible
you can't they're Classics it's like
saying I don't know I'm going to rewrite
I'm going to do Pride and Prejudice to
the sequel and hopefully people will
respect it as much as the original
they're not going to it's it's got to be
an expans an expansion or extension onto
that and hopefully you know you do good
films every franchise is the victim of
this but instead of trying to just do a
good movie on its own they have to do a
movie that expands upon or outd does the
previous and it's not
possible um too many streaming services
yeah um I I think that is going to I
don't it is already correcting itself in
a
way um I mean I saw a thing um about
Amazon the other day
or one of one of you guys shared it with
me actually it was the interview with um
the Mike right and the head of Amazon as
well um talking about MGM plus and how
Disney have always had this long-term
planning go you guys know this I've told
it's Millions times have this long-term
plan of becoming a hub for other
services so I have other sub channels s
to think and MGM plus is quite a popular
one so for the cost of like5 pounds a
month you get a lot of movies and it's
it's really to be fair I've got MGM plus
I got starget on it it's got loads of
films on there as well and it's it is a
good service I I quite like it it's one
of the ones it's like that and power
Mount actually worth having um I got rid
of Disney at the moment don't watch it I
do watch Starwatch Netflix um but those
are the two services bundles are going
to be the future so it'll be you spend
1010 pound on Netflix or you can spend
10 pound or you can spend 15 pound and
it'll be Netflix and Max or 20 pound and
it'll be Netflix Max and um probably
Paramount Plus in a bundle so you
basically it's cheaper if you have all
three sort of thing like 1750 or
something you get all three um so I'm
trying to get you to have all three or
you can have them individually for a
tener that's going to be the future
streaming
we probably will see a few streaming
services merge I think MGM and Lionsgate
are already kind of doing that at the
moment they're sort of merging those two
Services Amazon will will do that I
think Amazon will have two or three sort
of big sub channels MGM plus free
obviously um because they're different
types of services they'll have the
Amazon Prime and they'll have a couple
of other stars and things like that but
um it will they will have to go yeah
that's 100% we can't all afford them we
can't afford them there's a cost of
living crisis godamn it and um you know
we think we're you know we're watching
our pennies um and if the pennies watch
you know if you look after the pennies
the P will look after themselves it's an
old saying but it's true and at the end
of the day you're not going to watch all
these services and if anybody's got any
sense and it's the nice thing about
streaming services in a way if we could
be bothered to do it is that you can
turn them on and turn them off you know
you can go into something um book it for
a month cancel it immediately I do this
with apple never pay for Apple long term
have it for a month binge it turn it off
wait six months turn it on again binge
it turn it off that's the way and but
you can't really do that with other
things because they you know they they
they put barriers up to stop you doing
it excuse me
but you can with streaming services or
at least at the moment you can this is
one of the reasons why Netflix has deals
here in the UK I don't know about you
guys but here in the UK they have deals
with things like I have Sky TV and
because I have Sky TV I get Netflix free
so it's built into the price really I
don't get it for free Sky paying Netflix
you know they still get their money um
the price on sky goes up a little bit
you don't even notice but because it's
free I can't turn it on off and there's
no point with off because I've got sky
so I've already got the minimum package
on Sky I don't want anymore that's how
they do it and Paramount's the same
thing if I want Sky Cinema here I get
Paramount for free don't do that either
because the sky Cinema cost a fortune
and there's nothing on it all the movies
on the stream Sky Cinema used to be
really good here in the UK it used to
have all the new movies on it now it
doesn't because all the new Disney
movies go to Disney all the new paret
movies go you know what I mean so the
sky cinem is crap go they have some
terrible on
there it's all Sky
movies um I'm not
a keep hitting the wrong button here we
go need AMC without using a VPN to watch
all the Walking Dead spin-offs yeah
they're not available here yet um I'm
not a big fan of The Walking Dead I
don't like zombie movies I say give me a
rifle and enough ammunition I'll sort
out the zombie movie zombie issue no
bother but
um Sarah it feels like we gone full go
back to being like cable yeah well I
mean that because you know they're
starting to put adverts on them they're
starting to go back to the original
thing of oh we need another Revenue
stream
ads makes sense zom board yeah I I find
them boring um I I quite like that that
new one with the fungus thing that was
out um based on the game I
forgot Among Us I forget what it's
called um that was quite good
it does feel like and I don't know you
guys feel about this let me know it does
feel like though a lot of these
franchises are waking up it's took them
about three years but they've started to
realize they're losing
money
um and and I know people talk about
Marvel fatigue and Star Wars fatigue and
sci-fi fatigue and things I have always
said it's more about
quality they've made bad films because
they tried to make too many and they've
made bad films
and I think Star Wars has had a similar
problem they were trying to do too much
and they were making money and they went
let's make more and particularly with
Star Wars they didn't seem to try to
actually expand the universe everything
was still on or based around Tatooine
one or two characters and again Star
Wars seems to have figured that out now
so we are getting like a prequel movie
but a prequel movie that for me actually
makes sense because it's going back to
look at the birth of the Jedi Order that
sort of being developed alongside this
new Ray movie which is sort of The
Rebirth of the Jedi Order I can see that
those two projects are going to be
interesting Andor series two is coming
the first
season it was very clever I respected it
God it was a slow burn God it really
took yeah I you know you really has to
um yes thank you last of us um and and
you Peter well done
Last of Us I think I liked that less
than most people I think most people
really adored that series and I just
thought it was okay um even my kids
really liked it actually
um but with Star Wars sort of it does
seem to be trying to expand the universe
again now so I say we've got these
looking into the Jedi the birth of then
Rebirth of the Jedi there's um another
movie apparently the James uh no sorry
um there's another potential movie
that's going to be oh I just remember
the clip was um it's going to explore a
corner of the universe that we've never
seen before and characters we've never
seen
before or was that one of the TV series
I forget I'm not a big fan of Star Wars
um but again that seem to me make sense
they seem so focused on and Star Trek is
guilty of this as well so focused on the
characters that have been popular they
don't bother trying to expand the
universe at all and to be honest
Stargate is um at risk of this hey hton
it's just me sir so if you got any
questions by the way guys get into the
comments and I will answer them if I can
don't ask me what I know about Stargate
I can't tell you so don't
ask
um this
Mandalorian and drogou movie I knew
about this months
ago somebody told me about this ages ago
I thought it was open I thought it was
no um I because I don't really follow
Star Wars so um this got announced
yesterday I was like yeah I know about
that I've forgotten to I keep forgetting
to tell um Harris because he'd probably
really interested
but I just I forgot but anyway never
mind
um but yeah Star Trek is the same with
this how many Captain Kirks have we had
now are we on about the
ninth we're not but you know what I mean
we're we're on our third Captain Kirk
now why are they bringing Captain Kirk
in strange new WS
they're doing it because it's Captain
Kirk even though in Cannon we know that
Captain Kirk did not know Pike and I
think it said mentions he's maybe met
him once in the episode managerie though
it basically says he didn't know him um
Spock was obsessed with try to saving
his life and or letting him die I think
wasn't actually um but Spock was
obsessed because Spock's loyalty to him
but Kirk was kind of indifferent but now
thanks to Strange New worlds Kirk knows
Pike very well because Kirk keeps
turning up um you know I keep joking and
how are we going to do it next he's
going to go I forgot my keys I'm here
for my keys I forgot my wallet last time
I was here he just keeps turning
up um I'd love to see a chef a Star Trek
show not about Starfleet that would be a
nice way to expand the
Universe I like the Starships though I
have to admit I like the um space ships
and I like the um technology and
everything I I know where you're coming
from but then have to think of something
really intelligent about that because
um uh you know it would be
um it would have to
be uh something that was still
interesting something still sci-fi if
Harris knew maybe I told
him or maybe I just knew I said when it
was announced yesterday I was surprised
I thought everyone knew but um
maybe they did um I hate it when they
ignore Cannon except to create another
timeline I really want to talk about
other timelines there's an argument at
the moment that strange new worlds is
actually a third timeline and that's why
there's so much different it's actually
the only thing that makes sense um it's
lazy writing and this is a thing again
as I think the movie makers of Star Wars
Marvel everyone else I think they are
starting to wise up
to the fact that they will lose hundreds
of millions of dollars if they carry on
the path they've gone I think TV makers
are doing the same we don't want reboots
we don't like them they almost never
work they only get happened because they
are easier and they are easier than a
continuation if you do a continuation
you have to be clever you have to
explain 10 with Stargate um I just did
that SGU video about Stargate and I'm
saying trying to explain to everyone
that look it's not easy to restart
Stargate it's not going to be easy it's
going to have to take some thought it's
one of the reasons why I think it's
taking so long it's difficult to do a
continuation doing a reboot is a piece
of piss you have you have an original
content there to um no John but we we
will uh not at MGM mes there it's the
well there will be some MGM but it's
Amazon Prime and Amazon video but it
will include MGM yeah um it's going to
be several hundred um I'll come back to
that I forgot what I say I've got to
stop looking at the thing when I get on
a rant and I look at the comments on I'm
on a rant um but yeah TV makers are
wising up to the the fact that we don't
like reboots the battar galactic here is
probably the only reboot that ever
actually worked and even that went off
the rails towards the end um and had a
big gap between the original series and
the the
reboot every other time they've tried to
reboot it's not worked in my opinion
soft reboots and continuations they work
Star Trek worked because it was a
continuation other series are the same
Stargate has to be the same but it
requires effort it requires being clever
it requires doing a series that respects
what came before and you have to do
loads of research as well because you
have to know what came before for this
is one of the big reasons why it's so
important that Brad Wright or somebody
like that is involved in the new
stargame because he knows the material
otherwise you have to basically go back
and watch it all and make notes or
you're going to step on Cannon all the
time unintentionally sort of thing if
you don't know the history it's much
much easier to go oh that Star Trek G so
that's good I like that I'll just base a
new show on that and crack on with it
it's easier and you get a ready-made
audience you get to call it
Stargate but we don't like it and it
always fails and they seem to finally
finally figured it
out um the MGM layoffs so um it was
announced today um uh
Mike whatever his name is uh is the head
um one of the main guys basically Amazon
pictures he Jennifer saki's boss did
write a memo when he's basically saying
that look um we're constantly looking at
um everything that's going on the
streaming service everything's going in
the world and what our customers want
and we're constantly adapting to that
and because we're adapting and we're so
proactive we're sacking hundreds of you
um that basically what the the the memo
said
um job losses at MGM has been coming for
a while they didn't actually really sack
anyone um when Amazon took over they
didn't want any Nega
um any head negative headlines so they
just let people go by not renewing their
contracts and a lot of people that were
working at MGM were run short-term
contracts apparently it's quite common
in studios like this to have quite a few
people on short-term contracts they B
from contract to contract because
they'll say they start working on a show
to do I don't know the it work for a new
show or something or the they'll do the
digital work on a new show or whatever
they don't actually work for for MGM
they they will sort of work for the show
so they'll just be on a contract during
that show and then if that show ends
they will quite regularly jump onto
another show whatever but it's a new
contract so what MGM did was they just
didn't do it they just they just cancel
a loot of the contracts they just didn't
renew them um so they left a lot of
people
on
um um Doctor Who came back after Gone
Forever that was big as ever was yeah I
yeah no do did but that was like a
continuation so yeah exactly like Star
Trek had a continuation even with a big
gap
um it is in a way because it's a
different doctor isn't it so it is
plausible every time Doctor Who
generates it is a different because the
character is different it's it I mean
that's one of the big things they say
that he is different he goes oh I'm not
Ginger I'm got you know teeth it it is
supposed to be be a different character
um ah there you go so yeah I must have
heard the I was told by a
source God it must been three or four
months ago um but then it's been rumored
for a while I think that's what the
filon thing was he said because um even
back when the flon thing was announced
it was always said that it was going to
bring together Mando maybe Boba Fett and
a few other things wasn't it so yeah
fair enough maybe that's why I heard it
um
problem is you hear so
many I hear so many things um through
the different sources and people I speak
to sometimes you get a bit confused in
the way you've heard things the way you
haven't but anyway um or what you know
and what you don't know sometimes the
things stuff changes so quickly in this
industry the movie and TV industry I had
no
idea two and a half years ago when I
started sidet trk and I first started
talking to some of these people that
work in the industry
I had no clue I say none of them work
anywhere more than sometimes just six
months and they're gone they run to
another Studio they bounce around so
much the people I speak to almost all of
them worked at MGM when I first started
speaking to them not quite all of them
but but most of them um almost none of
them do now I I only have two or three
sources that work with MGM or Amazon um
I'm hoping I'm not going to get a
message at some point saying that
they've been made redundant but they
might have them um
but they now work all over the place
which is great for me because now I get
to hear rumors from everywhere um or
they work for um agencies doing doing
work for them or things which means
which Taps you into a different source
of of information
um
so do you think Stargate will turn into
Glee like Doctor Who
[Laughter]
did I'm not going to I'm not going to
touch
that but yeah it could do
um
so that that's brilliant but I hear
rumors about things and I say I don't I
don't share everything I hear because
sometimes you know it's just you you
know it's just talk um or I don't I'm
not interested if I hear stuff about
Star Wars generally I don't I don't
share it because I don't I'm not that
bothered and I and when I have done
videos about Star Wars they don't do
very well
so um you know I try to concentrate on
the things I think you guys want to hear
but if I'm excited if I'm interested by
something I will share it but it's
amazing how quickly things change I
reported that there was going to be a
disc World um movie um I actually um
Disney were looking at doing as an
animation movie and then they talk about
our live action blah blah
blah it's been scrapped since it changed
so quickly and but it just very quietly
got scrapped um if you Google it now
you'll see stories about it in the last
few months about how Disney they
struggled to get the movie rights and
all these other problems and which
normally isn't a problem for Disney but
for some reason they really struggled
with this but I think it's mainly
because Terry Prater just really didn't
want them to do it um and he he before
he you know he he made it difficult so
um and and they're very hard to do to be
fair his books are imaginative let's say
that but that was that was nailed on
Disney were doing it and then they just
weren't
um things like the 18 and um that reboot
we're talking about that that idea has
already changed about three times since
I first talked about it uh got 8 and9
months ago it was initially just
something executive thought like oh when
after the strikes we could do this I
have this universe and then we go oh we
could make it by Ai and now we could oh
we could do something else oh we can't
really do it with the 18 we don't really
own the rights well it doesn't really
fit in this new it just changes
constantly constantly constantly
[Music]
um um
so they don't they partly do um so
apparently they own some of the rights
to disr but they don't own all of them
um but they're not doing it anyway it's
not happening so um or at least not the
moment and it's been scrapped for now
[Music]
um
how big a failure was Stargate Origins
for the franchise do most even know it
exist to be honest it was an experiment
that was maybe
like I've always said the Stargate
Origins was illc conceived mainly
because they didn't go and knock on uh
Netflix's door and that was the mistake
MGM maybe they just didn't
realize what what Netflix was
becoming but it was early was it was it
201 17 2016 something like that Origins
somebody Google it for me quick it was
it was more recent than you think you
know I when I first thought about
Origins um I thought that was years
ago hey Cole how you doing
sir but it wasn't it was it wasn't that
it wasn't as long ago as you think um
and yeah it fa miserably because they
had this idea of putting on the internet
they thought that was the way they
thought they could have the Stargate
command and people would log on and pay
almost like a mini streaming
service and it was just illc conceived
it was it was just a bad idea from the
beginning I I can I completely see what
they were thinking but in 20 hindsight
is 2020 isn't it you know it's like look
back in it and go oh D what course it
didn't work but I honestly believe
Netflix would have took mgm's hand off
for that for that series they'd have got
more money they'd have got more time to
develop it and we'd have got a much
better project out of it um I think that
could have been a series that could have
worked the problem with Origins was it
was they didn't have any money they
nothing and it was um it was rushed
because of it so they didn't develop it
properly and it just didn't work um
that's one of those things there's not
one thing wrong with Stargate Origins it
the whole
thing was was do badly um and from but
from day one the whole concept for me
again with 2020
hindsight was was Ill conceived and as I
say that it screams Netflix Netflix I I
honestly think Netflix would have given
them serious money to develop that it's
perfect for them as well because it
would have been about six episodes they
could have explored two or three
different things we could have ended up
getting
Stargate you know you know one thing I
keep talking about is like a Stargate
prequel series um around the
um big finish is that thing I don't I
don't I don't know what that is
now
um 2018 you
um it doesn't sound right does it Dave I
can I when I looked it up and when when
it was actually produced I couldn't
believe how recent it was because it
feels like forever
ago but remember in this it was in 2019
Brad Wright was um asked to do the
script for the pilot end of
2019 so it was like they did Stargate
command it didn't really work but it
must have just given them enough
metadata or whatever to go okay this
didn't work but people were still
interested even though we didn't
advertise it nobody knew it was there
and we didn't spend any money on this
people actually still wanted to do it
people still wanted this to succeed sort
of thing
so that gave them enough confidence to
then go talk to
Brad obviously then covid and then
Amazon and then two years of delays but
it gave them the confidence so we should
be thankful for that that a very releas
the failure of Katherine's origin story
did lead into US almost getting what we
actually want which is a brad right
target
um ah jender Mary new subscriber thank
you very much
um
yeah I don't I know say I don't think
that's fair John I don't think Netflix
would have done that I think Netflix
have shown with things
like um strange stranger things and all
these other things that they've done
that Netflix love a good love sci-fi you
know they desperately wanted to keep
Star Trek they they paid money for um
for to Paramount to produce new Star
Trek even though it wasn't very good um
and you know they they love sci-fi and
they know they love sci-fi because
people watch it over and over again and
I think if they'd have got the right
people involved basically they' got MGM
involved and maybe got Brad Wright
involved was never really involved in um
Stargate command but if they got him
involved they could have done something
brilliant I think I would have loved to
have seen what they could have done
um guys I'm I'm being stupid I recent
big finishes relatively recent new
episode SG I haven't finished any of
them but big finished Doctor Who
episodes are brilliant so I'm hopeful
yet big finish Stargate is a thing I
don't know what big finish is I'm am I
missing something right obvious but I'm
sure if um in a in a minute my brain
will catch
up um he
congratulations well
done how much money are you giving
everybody else how much was it was it a
million quid because then you can um
share share the love sis share the love
um Harris if you're home let me know I
will send you a
link oh was it the fan fiction big
finish oh oh
okay I know what you mean um let me just
see if um Harris wants to come and say
[Music]
hello because he will want to talk about
Star Wars
because he is a Star Wars fan because he
is an idiot no he's not I don't I just
don't get the love of Star Wars if I'm
100%
honest kind a bit boring done Star Trek
better um we are going to do a um hey
Dax is
in um yeah I do what you mean see audio
books and things isn't it so
um the
um what was my
brain L I
say but yeah with Stargate I think if if
they'd have actually got away from this
Stargate command plan if they'd have got
out of this idea of this like mini
streaming service that they got so
focused
on it could have been good uh are you
still getting blood are you still giving
blood
Harris are you still giving your magic
hair
blood he getting M I need to inject some
in my face on R beard
this a week's growth I'm the least hairy
person that's ever lived did everybody
see stormies um
uh thing that he's not very well he's
got um he's got an infection in his bone
and he decided to put a picture of his
leg swollen and look painful but that
man has no leg hair I've got more leg
hair than him that was all I was
thinking about and we kept joking that
he's got he said a bone infection so I
immediately text back that he's got a
boner infection because us men we can't
just sympathize with people can we we
have to make a stupid joke out of it
because I really I love as stormy he is
my um I've known him for three or four
years now never met never met him in
real life and I and I love him um he's I
actually genuinely consider him a very
close friend so when he's not
well we worry but instead of just go in
mate I'm so sorry get well do everything
the doctor say mate and you know sort of
I have to make stupid penis jokes
because that's what men do it's how we
react to emotion we we poke um jokes at
it um says the man with an next swing
yeah
I I I
have complicated relationship with Star
Wars let's put it that way and my son
made that and it's freaking amazing um I
also have a Little Star Trek thing and I
have I have my little new Stargate as
well so I'm really happy with that I
haven't put batteries in it yet but it's
like a mirror thing in it pretty cool so
that's my little little presentation for
you in the back
um I'm like most most people that I love
the X-Wing I love the lightsaber I love
the noises um I love the visuals of Star
Wars I Mandalorian suit and blah the
visuals just on and on and on these
iconic moments as well in Star Wars and
I love them I find the films a bit long
I find them a little boring and I find
the story lines overly simple at
times um the latest Trilogy I thought
was three completely different movies
one was almost a comedy it was
ridiculous um but actually I quite
enjoyed them but I feel about that
trilogy almost like I feel about JJ
Abram Star Treks that I quite enjoy them
but they're not really Star Wars like JJ
Abrams they I quite enjoy those films
but they're not Star Trek I almost
that's not quite
Fair um but it's it's not it's not quite
the same thing but it's not far off
we're talking same ballpark here people
um and and the middle Trilogy or the
original trilogy the first Trilogy
chronologically
um had great moments in but on the
whole it's not the sort of film I got my
way to watch
the the series I find
them I always watch them always watch
them but the second I Mandalorian I
nearly stopped watching halfway through
because they it was such a slow
burn it was such a slow burn I nearly
stopped but then I I got into it and by
the end of the first season I was
completely on board I was like this is
great second season I actually loved
almost all the second season um Boba
Fett game the two episodes of
Mandalorian in and bobett wasn't in at
all was great the rest of the season n
Ming now wi I just I we should have done
Ming wi serious it would have been much
better um and then we had the third
season of Mandalorian I thought it was
stupid um we had Andor and I thought
actually even though that was again an
insanely Slow Burn I loved it and I
loved it in the same way that I loved um
the movie that um
prequels I want to say Rogue Squadron
Rogue one Rogue one which is one of my
again Rogue one is too long it should
have been like half an hour shorter it
would much better and it's one of the
best endings to a film ever but it was
you know not great it was it it's my
probably my favorite of the modern Star
Wars movies put it that
way see what everyone's
saying and
aoker was good on the whole I really
enjoyed the show okay I did struggle
with the space
whales there's some you have to have
some logical leaps with Star Wars there
are some elements you just have to go
that's just happened because it needed
to to make the story happen if you
actually engage brain at all and I'm not
going wrong Star Trek's guilty of this a
lot as well most
sci-fi but you know
it I the space whales were a problem um
and some of the other some of the other
relationships going on in aoka were a
bit of a problem they I'm not sure they
100% made sense and that one character
whose name I can't remember kept jumping
her allegiances and things like this but
on the whole on the whole I really
really enjoy the sh Mandalorian season
three on the whole I'll give it a b
at times it was an
F but other times it was an a you know
it it but it that that series
particularly in season 3 was all over
the bloody place
um and
um it shouldn't be that way again is I
think is this thing about over
complicating things and making you know
always having one eye on what came
before um are the space whales the perg
space Welles origin Rebels yeah I know
um I know did um Harris particularly was
um Furious when I said they were stupid
um because he is a massive Rebels fan um
and as a creature that lives in space I
have no problem with space whales even
though they look like
whales um we've had creatures that live
in Star Trek completely un board with it
why not
the fact that those space whales went
into hyperspace and stopped exactly
where they needed to that there that
their migration was exactly along the
same path that um huge hyperspace ring
had
gone that's the leap of logic that you
need you know I was even on board with
um that the fact that she could
psychically sort of talk to them but she
didn't know where they'd gone so she
didn't know where the whales needed to
go so some the only thing is that maybe
the whales sort of could smell the you
know the
hyperspace Trail and they followed them
but it didn't say that in the episode
but that would make
sense um Sabine yeah she didn't make
sense Sabine was the character in aoka
she just I don't know she was so
obsessed about getting her mate back
that she screwed I don't know um so
yeah I love the character of a show and
I love the actress she's great she was
brilliant in um the good episodes of um
Netflix's uh Daredevil as well she play
the nurse and that she played a few
things over the years she's such a
brilliant actress but they they cast her
perfectly um and that is one of the
things actually Star Wars has been
really good at um better than Star Trek
in the last few years that the casting
has been epic they're so good at it it's
a bit like Warner Brothers and DC
they're amazing at casting and terrible
actually then producing a film that
makes sense um but their casting is been
second absolutely second to know
um let's have a look what are people
saying Doctor Who did space whales as
well see now again no problem with life
in space
but they they did this in Star Trek in
Picard season 3 and it was the worst
episode they had this um nebula and it
was it kept going this energy wave kept
coming out and what we then realized
post was that it was It was supposed to
be
contractions and then basically the um
nebula went pop and it turned out it was
an egg and billions of these space um
they look like the things from the very
first Star Trek episode which I did
actually quite like I like that little
nod to that um it's a space jellyfish
basically
um and it was the from the encounter at
Faro episode when they um the the when
the and I don't know if you've ever seen
it but the encounter at Faro there's
this
Bas and it it can create anything it
wants but it turns out it's actually
it's it's a life form and when it then
turns back into its normal life form
turn looks like a big space
jellyfish um again a logical leap
because even if that only ever happened
every hundred million years or so surely
would have seen evidence of a nebula
going pop and a loads of space babies
coming out of it um and also where were
they so where were the eggs they were
flying around there flying faces and
everything at no point do they see
anything made no sense um the space
whales
again just a
um Rosario dwon thank you very much sir
yes she's fantastic but I I've never
seen her in bad in anything she's um
she's fantastic
is it really the 20th anniversary of
that already God I'm old 20th
anniversary of sga's Pilot Rising this
year it's 20 years since Target
Atlantis was premiering which means then
it's 15 years since we lost
it 13 years this year since we lost um
Universe it's a long time
guys not enough writers have grounded in
real science
anymore pet that's an interesting
point I think he can argue Star Trek's
always
struggled with actual
science and is science fiction so let's
we got to give it a fairness there is a
big fiction word there I I've argued
this with other stuff before though
science is in the sentence as well
though so you know there should be that
science and Star Trek you know know I I
I really do complain when the
science is just wrong in science fiction
like when they travel through a um black
hole to travel somewhere or they get
with the with the JJ Abram the first
movie they got the black hole
thing right and then horribly wrong so
if you've got a black hole in theory you
can time
travel because time slows down as the as
your as you get closer gravity increases
your mass increases time slows down time
dilation but then and then that is why
um the the Vulcan vessel the Vulcan
science vessel and Spock came out years
before um the the Romulan vessel
so but then we see the romul vessel
actually travel
through what they describe as a black
hole
now come on um it just doesn't make any
sense um warp drive has become yeah it's
it's i' there's um the obier drive which
is basically you take the mass of
something about the size of Jupiter and
push it down to the size of a marble and
that creates so much gravity the
gravitational force that you can then
distort space time and you can actually
just distort space so instead of
traveling fast and the speed of the
light what you actually do is sort of
create a fake wave that you ride along
and you pull where you're going towards
you and you push where you're going away
away from you and you and you can go and
you can beat sped light an engineer has
actually said it's gone from being
Theory to an engineering problem so we
know exactly how to do it we just don't
know how to do it um so we know what to
do not how so it's an engineering
problem so it is it is in
theory
possible
um don't get me started on the Kelvin
time live and science
accuracy they made the Enterprise water
powerered I'm just saying it was
hydroelectric the um that ship the
Enterprise in the JJ Abrams movies got a
massive refits because the the the way
the warp drive Works was completely
different in all three films never mind
that the ship was actually different why
did they do that why did they redesign
the why is the Enterprise different in
all three films makes no sense they did
that a little bit with the Enterprise E
in like between first Contact and the
movie that I tried to block for my
memory because I don't want to I want to
pretend it didn't
happen
Insurrection see I blocked it I'm I'm
blocking it really well so that I almost
forgot the name of it for a second the
Enterprise E does change slightly but
but it's so slight unless you actually
know and it was basically a thing
between um I can't remember if it was
first Contact and then Insurrection they
had a Model A real model for the first
movie but then they went fully digital
in the second movie so there was some
slight
differences
um that you wouldn't know you can tell
with the JJ Abrams movies one of the
changes this just shows how little JJ
Abrams gives a about Star Trek um
they wanted the the neck in the sorer
section to be longer and thinner so that
when those enemy vessels that could cut
through when they cut through the neck
and the sorcer section and the drive
section break
apart they wanted it to look more
fragile so they elongated the neck and
made it
thinner do they not know Star Trek fans
do they not know that that is the sort
of thing that really really annoys us
that that is the sort of thing that wh
Star Trek fans right up when they change
things like that for no good
reason we buy technical manuals for
these things that's why JJ Abrams has no
no clue about Star Trek fans he knows
how to make a visually interesting movie
but he has no clue about Star Trek fans
and somebody that isn't a geek for it
shouldn't be anywhere shouldn't be
anywhere bloody near the franchise if
you think that doing a changing the
design of the Enterprise just because
you visually want something to look
right shouldn't be allowed it
um it's pretty
bad sorry guys I'm a bit bunged
up got a bit of a head cold so
um it's it's movie material but episode
of the week material and I I would give
you that it is it's like an O to be fair
we would been a pretty good double
episode of Star Trek the Next
Generation I've never really thought
about it like that and yes actually it
probably would have done I could see
that being a really interesting double
episode what was the TNG episode with
the Bor um it was the last time we saw
law uh I do know what it was
called um it would have been season
six or seven probably seven um it had a
similar feel to it like that did to be
honest
and yeah interaction would have made
quite an
interesting episode double episode it's
just not a
movie might have been descent yeah the
film with
Hugh the one with Hugh descent part one
and two thank you
um but um
I I think I think Insurrection had a
sort of similar sort of feel to it like
that but I think by the time we got to
descent they were spending proper money
on Star Trek so that those TNG episodes
felt more like more cinematic than um
Best of Both Worlds maybe did but Best
of Both Worlds is obviously a million
times better
um yeah um I think kurtzman is the
same it's style over
substance with both of them
Abrams is and and kurtman is Abrams
bloody you know I was going to say negl
is his negl um is his prodige you know
remember kurtzman worked on the JJ abrs
movies that's why we saw the the
Abomination which was the Klingons in
the first series of Discovery because he
drew on that from the JJ ABS movies and
brought it into the series and then we
had these plasticine Klingons creepy
cling on
um this should never been allowed and
but that is again a perfect example and
thank you Colin of they shouldn't be
allowed anywhere near it because they
don't respect the show and if you don't
respect the show and if you're more
worried about it looking pretty than
actually making sense and being loyal to
the fans and everything else then you
shouldn't be allowed anywhere
near um that thing
yeah have just done Aira adaptations for
Leo yeah yes I know they have yet um
Mark Ferguson hwk HBY with the um team
that they're trying to do penguin and
Parker they're trying to create a
production company they hired a bunch of
new people um about six months ago
they're trying to create um a little
Empire they will not be doing one
project at a time they're going to be
doing three or four different projects
at a time um that's what they're trying
to build they're trying to build a
proper production company so think about
you know they're looking at things like
sky dance and they want to do that sort
of level of um work um you think about
um oh Seth Rogan and his production
company where he's got three or four
different things going on at once that's
what they want to do with Partners in
partnership with other people but um
that's what they're trying to do uh yes
Harris yes we did
um on my understanding the bulk of it is
I've only spoken to one person about
this but my understand is the bulk of it
is going to be prime um um uh Prime
video is going to be a lot of it and uh
it's not going to be a massive move on
the um MGM and
Prime um because they they're shifting
they've shifted a lot of the priority
already over to
cinema and movies so um they've already
done a lot of the work but there's a lot
of things that they were doing before
that they're not anymore more and it's
easier and quicker just to make people
redundant it shouldn't be but it is
um I haven't read any in or I haven't
listened to any of those in a while but
I will I will find out because um they
are really really
good yep um Mark Ferguson HW wrote Iron
Man um they also wrote that um movie
um
men Children of Men they wrote Children
of Men as well uh and did some of the
development work so yeah they've theyve
they've both got um I think that might
have been that might have just been Mark
Fergus though might not have been HW HBY
but um generally but you know they're
supposed to be doing four or five
different projects but Mark Fergus is is
on the wants to do Stargate it'll be he
will that will be his baby so there'll
be lots of other projects going on um
um I know it's being produced I know
it's coming um I'm not sure when I
didn't see a question sorry Colin um I
got a lot of comments I'm sure you sure
you sure so I'm sure you know but um it
can be quite difficult to keep up um my
understanding was it
was I know it was delayed because of the
strikes but I feel I think filming had
already
started but yes it will be the final
season
which would be a shame um first season
of Resident alien was so good but um the
the second season wandered a little bit
but then the third season came back
really strong really really
good the rage cling on any word on
SG much can I
say
right there has been a little bit of
movement on
Stargate um but I don't want to talk
about it too much because I'm not sure
there's basically two possibilities
going on at the moment and I don't want
to talk about it too much because I'm
not sure which way they're going to go
and I don't want to disappoint you guys
by saying one thing and then it you know
happens I know a lot of people getting
quite irritated by um Amazon's you know
I I feel like sometimes I get blamed
because of Amazon's you know um keep
changing their mind and things but um
there is two possibilities about an
announcement in the next six months put
it that way um and one is very
[Music]
um one or both of these things is going
to happen it will happen it's just when
um but San Diego ComicCon is what we're
going to be looking at what we're going
to be looking for it's just whether
it'll be announcement or whether it
they'll just turn that into a bit of a
Stargate event that's the question at
the
moment my understanding is the same
basically we've said for the last um 18
months that Amanda tappin and Michael
Shanks have had conversations but
they're not allowed to talk about
it and those conversations have been
very limited but it's more along the
lines of if we were to do this what
would you you know and that is very
possible they they know who they want to
who um be the main star but they haven't
signed on um and apparently it does look
like there is a
director um but I can't say any more
than that so we have to leave it at that
I can't I can't say any that's already
me saying way way way too much uh Rocky
I did a movie I did a video on it
yesterday so that's happening uh script
is done
we know that that's been confirmed by
Patrick himself the uh movie will begin
filming um I my understanding is it'll
be by the end of this year they'll start
filming um it'll be on a Paramount plus
by the uh Autumn of next year and um
it'll be followed very closely by
Legacy basically that's my understanding
um the filming of Legacy and the Bard
movie will overlap with each other
and there's going to be elements of both
within the movie we're going to see
Legacy crew in the movie um apparently
and then that will that will Kickstart
Legacy and that's the plan
currently
so and Jonathan FRS will be
directing so there you good um got to
respect the
sources watch Wolf Pack it's actually
actually quite good it's actually all
right but I might be
slightly um in love with Sam Michelle
Galla a little bit so I might be you
know leaning that way because I love her
and anybody says anything bad about it
um I will be angry but guys I am going
to say good evening I am going to go and
watch an episode of um season five of
Yellowstone because my my God that's a
good TV show and um it makes me want to
be more manly I'm not manly enough I do
too much like cooking and cleaning and
things I need to start like punching
people and stuff more often and be like
manly and riding horses I hate horses
but I could get a motorbike that's
similar so I'm going to go do that thank
you so much for um having a chat with us
guys again you're amazing and keep it in
the uh you know keeping me going in
there even though distract me sometimes
and you know who um yeah got head cold I
get them all the time a sinus problem I
always bunged up but um I will
survive um thank you hund good night uh
everybody cocka and yes Bob you always
always wind me up distract me anyway
what's wrong with horses there's nothing
wrong with them they're just really big
scare me a little bit I've never I've
never been on a horse so this you know
it's an unknown entity to me but my God
they're beautiful I watch um I was um I
go walking on shopia Hills by where I
live sometimes um I go hiking over there
and there are wild horses on there
they're only ponies really watching them
running it's amazing it's amazing and
they're absolutely beautiful
um I keep hoping war will get pulled up
by
HR um but yes thank you so much guys
have an amazing couple of days um
tomorrow's video is going to be about
Tron 3 and then um on Friday I've done
another video and you honestly I can't
remember what it's
about so look forward to that that'll be
out in the next couple of days have
fun stay safe as always and um you know
subscribe and do all those things if
you're new to the channel speak you
later
guys sh